warum haben wir denn hier schlüssel 1
und eine weitere belohnung ein smaragd
mensch
da hinauf
hey das ist immer so derbe knapp
erst wird das war schon knapp dann
können wir jetzt nichts sagen
yeah
datenserver die muss jetzt hinten rein
stimmt so offen
das muss die welt retten
alter sich muss ich krank es dich schon
mal aufgefallen ist das gebäude total
katastrophal konzipiert ist stimmt ab
für den ort der nächsten weihnachtsfeier
erst mal eine runde darüber pennen
ich denke die ganze dass von irgendwoher
ding kommt oder so faxe michael hallo
ich bin eine ablenkung freut mich
richtiggehend unsere simulation gibt
ihnen diese täuschend echte umgebung für
einen einsatz im freien zu simulieren
kein golem wartet noch auf seine rettung
wartet noch auf seine rettung los alter
noch dieser park ist schon geil aus 11
59 05 1 2
er war 817 komplett fertig ist der
terror 0 1 2 1 treffer
turm in der in der ferne ich musste
damals archibald befreie archibald aus
einem netz aus seinem käfig löse dazu
das wundersame rätsel der absoluten
rätselhaftigkeit und das befindet sich
da ich will doch nur spielen nicht wenig
ist vorsicht das monatlich könnte dir
die augen ausbrennen das brutzelt dann
so lustig dieses schild simuliert deine
instinkte da lang manager ich kann ihn
irgendwo her das ist so wie bei dieser
zelda dings web ahnung ich das sein soll
da freu dich okay ich freue mich jetzt
bestimmt auch noch etwas egal was steht
2051 teilen ist zwar auf dem sein aber
okay so was ist hier wundersames rätsel
der absoluten rät saftigkeit tsd
der erste zu befreien de gaulle an hieß
albert smaragde stellen ein punktestand
dgb bedeutet kohlen befreiungs einheit
sie können lesen
die simulation ist absolut
realitätsgetreu der letzte zu befreien
de golem spongebob nein nein leute der
erste zu befreien de gaulle hieß albert
nein er hieß gilbert des marktes stellen
ein punkt der standard gb bedeutet golem
befreiung beglückung einheit ist falsch
sie können lesen ja kann ich diese
simulation ist absolut realitätsgetreue
nein der letzte zu befreien der grünen
spongebob nein
nein das wäre auf antworten nein
nein ja oder nein nein nein nein nein ja
na gut ich lass uns jetzt erst mal so
ich schaue mal ob der golem freigelassen
wurde ich dachte bei einer falschen von
welchen in die lava gekippt oder sowas
wer auch witzig gewesen als jetzt nicht
ganz so witzig aber nico damm ist immer
noch da
gut dann ist nein wahrscheinlich dann ja
nein ja nein nein nein ja ja nein nein
nein herr sauber der nähe das stimmt
auch nicht diese sieben teams absolut
realitätsgetreu ich lasse es einfach an
so schauen wir nun ob der kohle noch da
drin ist
den trend intendantinnen und intendanten
studenten könnten
und mittendrin so das heißt ich mache
mir noch mal auf das nein auf ja
irgendwie so sie kann lesen gepäck holen
beglückung einheit zwar gestellt den
punktestand der sätze befreien konnte
der rest stimmte jetzt da stimmte alles
die denn ist doch alles richtig
lasst mich dings befreien archibald
manche bald ist noch da
ich muss da hängt ein schalter drückt
man irgendwie sowas oder bestimmt stimmt
das gar nicht diesem rätsel die falschen
mich wieder so meine theorie
so nein ja der letzte befreiende kohle
heißt sponge bob miner heißt welt diese
simulation ist absolut realitätsgetreu
jahr ist sie sie können lesen ja kann
ich
oder nein der glücklos eines coolen
befreiungsschlag der stellen ein
punktestand daria tun sie der erste zu
befreien hieß albert filbert fakt dass
deswegen war das falsch ach so dann muss
das zu machen jetzt bei gott ich sage
noch am anfang der us- gilbert und dann
mache ich das einfach so woche zu blöd
damit stand er wieder 1000 leute in
combat geschrieben ja ich weiss ich blöd
dahinter ist auf bald ist gerettet
das war realistisch nicht war alles was
gut sie haben allerdings befreit begeben
sie sich nun zur lobby on the way patch
soll dass man es merkt
das heißt insgesamt 17 smaragde nacht
machen normalrunde penan mein handy
bimmelt die ganze zeit so
zum spaßbad mit rutsche
so seien so lobby vorsicht scharfe kurve
lobby öffnen herunter
was haben wir denn hier
kaum zu glauben hier ist nichts ja das
hätte ich mir schon denken können sich
der schulter gesehen hat
übrigens auch geil das ist nicht
wirklich sein klotz ist sondern dass
überall das alles noch so ein bisschen
ich würde schon sagen sie ziert ein
bisschen
jetzt hilft mir das wert
jetzt wirklich nix
es auch so ein bisschen tue
m
nicht fasziniert sie ziert und ich
inspiriert noch ein bisschen verziertes
verziert als ein bisschen verziertes
draußen mit so alle möglichen wie zum
beispiel ließ und so frau was haben wir
denn hier
schlüssel 1 und eine weitere belohnung
landmark in emerald lobby ich bin
buchsbaum da bist waffe oder bin ich so
haben wir dann so eine coole
wendeltreppe aussichtsturm dagegen 1
kurshoch de gibt tipps
ich will mich gerade wie den eifelturm
hoch gelaufen bin
danke verdient sich an als wenn
irgendwelche mein karlsruher so wir
haben 30 amerells ist doch schon eine
ganz gute ausbeute finde ich
stellt man muss empfindet auch da muss
die nicht ganz so blöd weit drehen
das ist okay ich lasse sich mal wieder
unter den linden
mit dem minden
im winter nicht stück fest
sowas habe ich hier lobby ist aber zu
machen auch wenn es ein feines schiesser
gott nein bitte nicht
der kürbis sagt merk wie
wie jetzt
he
für solche nachteile hin schießen bitte
auch sagt bitten ihrer des falls
komplett umsonst dass ich diesen sturm
laufen bin muss der normale hochlaufen
tipps und ich habe schon wieder zwei
pfeile verschwendet dass es auch mal
wieder so richtig beim kontrast hervor
von denen erst dann geklärt
das hatte schon vergangenes cloud
geklaut war es wieder ein foul
dann muss ich hier wahrscheinlich etwas
abschied online
oh gott
denk mal getroffen das gibt eine anzeige
an alle besucher die level öffnen zum
ford aussichtsturm bitte alle auf einmal
mittel auf einmal erscheint ein
zwischenfall auf dem kurz weg gegeben zu
haben wir halten sie auf dem laufenden
auf einmal durchlaufen
naja ich werde so den turm unterlaufen
das ist deutlich angenehmer
und ich muss nicht die ganze zeit meine
maus bewegen und ihr seht nur treppen
das natürlich dann auch sehr gut als
zuschauer
lobby geöffnet they have been abend so
hier ist ein buch noch sein buch gbr
agency sind ein hervorragender mann nun
nach all den tests und prüfungen
hervorragend wird damit vorgeschriebene
fahre ich glaube schon
deutschrocker
kein trinkwasser service heißt ja nicht
im service höher
luca rana gemacht bitte schön danke
danke echt voll nett von denen unser ich
hab keinen bock darüber zu laufen
nicht in das becken pinkeln büroräume
für mit dem korridor alter das sieht
aber auch geld ausgegangen da wartet
noch mal ganz kurz
ich zeige euch mal ganz glücklich dass
mit schildern aussieht dann schildert
sie das geil aus auf meinem pc erwarte
ich aber noch diese schere die super
leid ich habe mir alle möglichen stellen
nehmen sie das eigentlich ich weiß nicht
ich aber man soll diese map ja komplett
mit dem die volltext spielen deswegen
spiele ich gerade ohne shader rezeption
aber es geht unsere klingen lässt
willkommen bei der gbg wir sind voll die
tolle firma wir machen allerlei crazy
zeugs wir bilden erstklassige fachkräfte
aus wir sind verantwortlich für über 70
prozent des co2 ausstoßes wir retten ab
und an mal ein paar golems wir
trainieren aber auch reinigungspersonal
oh mein gott oh gott ich koche seiten
ausgang bei feuer geschlossen um panik
zu verbreiten
darum sind kästen kann ich denn nicht
hierher
ich will hier geht's namen aber ich darf
kein blogger komplett kaputt machen